so blackman's board with two outs here's
aaron otto
the left field off the end of the bat
grossman hustling toward the line and
into foul territory a nice running catch
armand went five two thirds against
texas
and that's a strikeout on three pitches
to begin things that's a nice way to uh
start your afternoon simeon is gone one
out that'll bring up lorianno
and
that's six pitches and two strikeouts
that was a back-up slider that worked
out effectively
chapman is five for 19 but four for
seven in his last two games that one is
belted to left field hilliard's back and
that baby is gone may have clipped the
top of the wall doesn't matter
and chapman has his first home run of
the year
this ball
got out of town quick fast and in a
hurry 105 miles an hour one out bases
loaded only a couple of uh rbis already
this year
and this ball is lifted to deep right
field way back going near the wall
leaping can't catch it is biscotti
that should score at least two or one
that's a strange one you hit it off the
top of the wall with the bases loaded
you get only one rbi
and that is because mcmahon at second
had to wait
big out here trevor story
olson off his foot picked that by
machine throws to first and olson gets
back and the a's get out of it with just
the one run scored so it wasn't pretty
but the a's get the third out and
they'll take it grossman off to his lead
at first
2-1 pitch is hit to the left side diving
stop byronado to second for one onto
first not quite in time
boy nolan did a great job of snagging
that ground ball on a dive
got it to garrett hampson
and only piscotty speed
prevented the double play rockies 1-1
with the a's as we go to the bottom of
the third sean murphy the catcher in the
nine hole to start it off against airmon
marquez
murphy didn't want to leave but he's got
to swing in a miss another strikeout for
airmon marquez as he came back and got
simeon on a pitch to the outer half and
that is a rather dominant inning one two
three mcmahon at third and hilliard at
first and here's garrett hampton rocky's
looking to jump into the lead this ball
pulled to deep left field grossman
coming on makes the catch on the move
mcmahon is tagging and mcmahon will
score hampson makes it 2-1 colorado two
on two out a's down two to one in the
fourth and here's piscotty
nolan's got it
what
that's interesting he gets he out the
third out at the plate
why did he do that
just forgot
well it worked out yeah
olson shocked nolan's smiling he goes
back it's different way to get the third
out 3-2 again breaking ball hit the
trevor story at shore down over to first
six solid innings by airmen marcus 2-1
rocky now charlie blackman charlie is
single in three tries this is lied the
other way it's gonna get down into that
uh
narrow corner and story's gonna head
home
trevor with the great wheels will score
on the double by blackman make it 3-1
colorado
speed never has a bad day
and trevor's story such a good base
runner with good speed
saw the trouble and got the wave home
from stu cole so the rockies with a pair
of hits to begin the eighth are up three
to one base is loaded two hot bottom of
the eighth take one more pit chiro
02
did he go step on home plate yes he did
diaz strikes out grossman and the a's
leave him loaded
oh jairo diaz works out of a jam again
boy charlie could deliver here 3-2
back up the middle off of lazardo
and he lobbed it is he safe at first the
run scores and trevor scores trevor
scored all the way from first how do you
like that trevor was at second let me
mention that okay how about
the hustle from charlie down the line
now the rockies need three outs
to celebrate their fourth victory in
five outings
on the ground toward the hole diving
stop throw to first out at first base
great play by chris owings oh what a
play by ceo yeah it was absolutely
beautiful
el monte kicks and fires this is hit the
right charlie blackman coming on it sunk
and he had to go down to his knees but
he stayed with it for out number two
and a fly ball
this is shallow right owings has it and
the rockies have won four of five to
begin
the 2020 season all out on the road